[Music]  the nevada national guard's involvement  with regards to the pandemic will end a  week from tomorrow exactly two years  after the guard's assistance began this  marked the largest domestic emergency  response in nevada history and the  lengthiest assisting with covet testing  contact tracing meal and ppe delivery  data processing call centers and lab  support to name a few the nevada  national guard has never been busier or  more visible these past two years  this is probably the greatest um  crisis we've faced in the last hundred  years of really world war ii  uh if you exclude current uh current  world situation and uh every guard  member that was asked to step up did  step up we had more volunteers than we  had actual work to do  yesterday members of the guard were at  the state lab looking at deficiencies  and challenges in that department the  guard says it will be advocating on that  department's behalf to increase their  capacity